might be sleeping Joe Mallya is how yeah
yeah yes he's like that my own phone to
the Jamali and president to talk hey
everybody everybody and this is gonna be
our last video of the day maybe our last
video we don't even know how we're in
this movie we're you know it's like
post-apocalyptic and we're like hey
anybody out there just listening she can
use his last video anyone out there
had that same thought when I was
vlogging yesterday I was vlogging and I
was like I was you know just talking
normally and I started that brought that
thought crews by my mind and it was like
what if no one's ever gonna see ya
anybody out there out there after the
corona pandemic and it's not a zombie
apocalypse yeah exactly
we're gonna die overnight you seen that
movie movie goes no it's not like we're
gonna die you know the guy that's that's
gonna be the first one to die you can't
thank know it I won't die if you die it
does feel like some [ __ ] yeah at the
same time to like I'm trying to be
optimistic I'm just like well everyone
does that part like I just want to catch
it already so I'm like I feel like we
all did the flu or cold okay that theory
a theory of like Jerry remember the
theater well there's a theory that LA or
the US has already had it for a while
like like October because remember when
everyone got sick late December early
January like everybody had the same type
of thing where even people that got flu
shots they had flu-like symptoms they
got a fever
it turned into an either pneumonia or
bronchitis or something respiratory and
then like cuz I got sick I got sick but
I needed antibiotics so it was
definitely bacterial it's not like a
virus I didn't go to the hospital but I
needed to
no you didn't have it then Ryan I guess
not
hey we had to go we know what we did we
sat down a [ __ ] table together in the
Santa know doctor went up losing oh yeah
yeah whatever
that was the $900 oh my god we have to
pay the full freight it got knocked down
from there and then we ended up but
that's yeah because of insurance that is
the exact same reason why that time when
I got it and I legit felt like I was
going to die yeah calling about life
insurance Casey and Isaac will be okay I
really thought I was gonna die I still
didn't go to the hospital because I'm
like it's too expensive we have
insurance yeah it's still too expensive
yeah so I'm like listen I'll just die
it's okay they're taking care of it's so
true what funerals are all so expensive
so that's kind of rude of you if you
wanna if you wanted to you want a
tragedy funeral well she paused the
funeral in Paris something she's like I
said I have life insurance please spend
it properly my trashy Villa is you bury
me with [ __ ] in the Air Jordans box
yeah we're gonna say oh so we cremate
yeah yeah she's originator do you wear
Jordans or anything what does it mean to
you I've had it for a long time where I
told my representation I was like listen
this is gonna get to a point where you
guys are gonna have to pay me in Air
Jordans and they're like okay yeah yeah
okay and I was like yeah listen like I
just want to be paid in Air Jordans
gonna want to [ __ ] deal with a little
[ __ ]
like like that's like if I need money at
the time I'll sell box the Air Jordans
or whatever than like so what are we
supposed to do we're supposed to take
the amount of money that you're owed and
just buy Air Jordans and chip-ins your
house and I was like yeah that sounds
fun just like Jesus this is why I run
the finances at home no because I would
have gone to worship for the bet that
it's bad so you would wear like bit
yourself to do
I would air jordan earl grade myself
into pour pour I mean Earl Grey Earl
Grey's are very expensive Air Jordans
and I don't know much about our droids
but we're talking about all I know I
know that's alright Jordans is that a
thing bring in the to the tea that's
like a color the team Earl bridge is the
most famous everyone great no the most
famous black 8english black breakfast
tea no no but the Earl Grey's are the
gray Jordans that everyone no no he's
not though yeah he really genuinely
friendly entity he is right now
but before that he wasn't you always
like it wasn't Eve he was you got
trolled yours video might as well give
it all out let's get all up what's it
the real [ __ ] up this is the last jake
kinney's episode what are your guys is
message you said that Joe's not here yes
can't be the last one will be the second
the last we have to do that group chat
facetiming thing that will do it we'll
do it without Joe is just okay true was
just the Jay Ashley oh yeah without Jeff
one time I had a [ __ ] and then
disrespect you know what I mean
[Laughter]
three two one anyway so that I was doing
this thing and that the thing that's
very important that we have to hold up
the shoot so I can tell you this thing
that was good I think he's doing fine I
think he's playing baby baby are you
homie alright and he didn't reply it's
like being a sleeping
oh no he might be dead like it's dead
it's right now join us right now
excuse the bed the bed audio honey use
FaceTime if it had anything it's cuz if
we use so you guys know if we use the
radio signals it [ __ ] up though the
mics and it goes like so if you're
experiencing that right now anyway
you men might be sleeping Joe Mallya is
how you have yeah yeah yes he's like
that my inferred to the Jamali and
president answered
for jay king he knows his particulars we
tried we tried he's probably sleeping
yeah you know that always really jacking
off sleep in our plane deal there's
planes piano making it like just got in
the shower there's water just dripping
on the floor I know what are you gonna
do we don't come in maybe the worst is
in my life what have you been doing to
get your social meter up I've been
writing he goes to restaurants and
eavesdrops on a 60 year old woman's
birthday I did that when when
restaurants were open that was like when
so that's gonna mean he wasn't even in
isolation for very long it was like two
days have to be around people I do a
half-two grocery store for you grocery
stores fine that they do fine
now you better that was good we could
just have face time party okay you want
me to do impressions of people and like
a child
with the Nikki that's talks inside her
mouth this is why she was alone for so
many years
finding alone forever yeah she really
feared it out
I would go like hardly ever had people
around me and then I was babysat by this
old Greek lady and she would like take
naps throughout like the majority of the
day Wow so I would just pretend out with
someone to talk to so I'd be like hey
how's it going cool like I was watching
Power Rangers but now it's over real
[ __ ] conversation yeah you are
nothing really good in there yeah do it
go built by loneliness imagine how are
you react if you met someone who could
do it to and they're like oh my god I
did that too as a kid that would be
amazing I met I've seen a few people
that can do it online but I don't know
if the reason they can do it is the same
is that satisfy I needed a gimmick a
silly shitty gimmick and think it's like
I needed to be yeah oh that's not my
shitty gimmick my shitty gimmick is this
I could touch my toe to my head oh
you're right that is shittier yeah I
can't do that you can't
no questions here I can suck my own dick
well yeah you definitely win then you
should do that maybe you don't need me
oh [ __ ] yeah well you're pretty close
how come you get projects like most the
times like at home like even during this
week when there's like all the group
chats are exploding I'm like I'm too
busy for this Wow [ __ ] I know you've
been silent yeah I get busy I like
getting I like working on things and I
like getting in a zone and I don't like
distractions like when I'm working on
can you give me something to be busy
about that doesn't have to do with my
house cause stressing me out too much
yeah I'm actually one of the things I
was busy on was planning videos and one
of my videos is 55 things to do alone oh
yeah what was gonna be fifty
but then I just kept going and I
actually to stop myself because I
probably could have gone to like oh yeah
hey that scares me why don't you just do
it because that probably monetizing 100
sounds better because I was like often
have to film a hundred things well why
don't you why don't you split them up
into five parts like ten each
oh my multiple video maybe five more
things to do a low 250 huh I could I
don't think you do 300,000 scares
because she cares gonna be annoying
Steve like she's gonna get to the point
where she's like really I could poke
them in the butt again you know what I
really wanted to count how many hairs I
had in my head oh my god you would yeah
but I do what did you start the ambition
to count on my child what's the highest
you've ever counted easily I tried to
get to a thousand but I couldn't okay
your husband [ __ ] bust a gut on that
one
that's how over the [ __ ] part you
know what I did um when I was younger
too and I spent a [ __ ] time alone - for
some reason thought I don't know I'm
really [ __ ] weird where I kind of
like pain a little bit like physical
pain
my mom's tweezers and I would pluck out
every soul hair on my knee and then I
would move down to my shin and then I
move up to my thigh but I didn't get you
sir
yeah with tweezers and but I really get
that home I thought oh yeah she's
actually had that in like in uh like
middle school like I got stressed about
it realized this thing I just start like
pulling my hair out that's an actual
thing that I stopped it because I
realized it's time to pull it out too
much too much hair it's like a
stress-related right about here
I brought her yeah I mean I still do
that for like just the middle though
like I did that when I was in like
middle school and then chicks called me
out on it and I was like no like there's
this
[Music]
it's the worst defense was like redness
right just blame there on the cold sore
instead of saying that I was trying to
narrow off my money but I didn't believe
in a cold sorry it looked bad though it
was like a bird and then it was [ __ ]
and Dan that's real bad too like a scab
like a puss yeah burn scab and I was
like it's a cool surprise I thought my
mom I got this then after that it was
really easy to pluck the hairs oh
because it like lost feeling there
that's a silver lining and yes I didn't
flick it but with scissors I just went
all clean in my nose hairs I was like 10
years did you breathe this is the best
year ever
- it was to clean and then like my
boogers kept running out needs a lot
Gina fetch that Oliver and stuff kept
coming out all of that and I was like
girl I know exactly what you're talking
about
and then but I used to it so my mom
found out when I was doing with her
tweezers and she took them away and
during that time I had already like
tried flicking up my eyebrows and then
they started growing back so I'm like
[ __ ] I don't my eyebrows still look
gross and I started plucking with my
nails so I literally plug in my eyebrow
you had a my strange-looking eyebrows
and hair's got skills I did and then
once I start getting armpit hair I kind
of like the paint a little bit I just
wanted to feel something weird yeah I
think I can't feel it just wanted to
feel something okay doing it and then
now that I laser sometimes like four or
five hairs come out so instead of
shaving I should plug about well looks
like four or five honestly yeah it's not
like you get four Tings of pleasure I do
you get excited you're just like oh
growing these babies at the PUC later
[Music]
[Music]